welcome to exploring computing
today's video is bits bytes and binary
part 3 or how to destroy a rocket with
only 16 bits
so in this video we're going to take a
look at what happens when things go
wrong
i'm going to start off with a story
about a rather expensive
error where the source of the error was
the programmers chose the wrong number
of bits
we're going to go back to the year 1996
the european space agency has a new
rocket the ariane 5 which is
as you might guess a follow-on to the
aryan 4.
on board this new aryan 5 rocket are
four
satellites worth 370 million dollars
the rocket launches three two
one fire
things look like they're going well and
then 37 seconds into the flight the
rocket starts veering wildly off course
it starts breaking apart and ultimately
it has to be destroyed
what went wrong what went wrong was
in one place the program controlling the
rockets tried to store information in 16
bits
as you might recall in 16 bits we can
store numbers as large as
2 to the 16 which means we can store
numbers between 0 and 65
535 and while this number was large
enough for the aryan 4
the predecessor to the air and 5 the
aryan 5
had performance characteristics that
caused it to run much faster
and the value that it tried to stick in
this to the 16-bit
storage location did not fit and when it
tried to put the value into 16 bits
what ended up happening is we had a
condition called overflow
and what can happen in overflow is we
can have a really large number and add
one to it and end up with zero
or we can have a large positive number
add one to it and actually end up with a
large negative number
so we're going to take a look at this
phenomenon in a minute this phenomenon
is also related to
another famous problem which is the y2k
problem i know this is
a little bit before some of your time so
you may
be thinking yeah my parents might be
interested in this lecture
but um what happened with the y2k
problem is that
programmers starting in the 50s were
trying to save space
in their computer programs and so when
they tried to store the year
they didn't store the full year with all
four digits
instead they would store just two digits
so here's a little table for example so
let's say the programmer was interested
in storing the year 1952
they would just start 52 and then
when that 52 got red from computer
memory
the computer would just know oh i need
to add a 1 9 to it
and so this would go on 1984 distort 84
95 star 95 but the problem is you can
see here is
when we start getting closer and closer
to the year 2000
the programmers realize they have a bit
of a problem
if they just store zero zero and they do
not fix their program the program is
going to think that the year 0
0 represents the year 1900 not the year
2000 and so this was the y2k problem
and what ended up happening was we had
to spend
millions and millions of dollars
rewriting computer programs so that
when the year 2000 hit the computers
didn't think we were back in the 1900s
all right so let's take a look at how
overflow actually works i'm going to
show you two different versions of
overflow
in the first version of this we're going
to take a look at what happens when
we're storing
positive integers so i'm going to stick
with 8 bits
although typically these numbers will be
much larger but it'll be easier to
understand we only use 8 bits so in 8
bits if i'm
only storing positive numbers we can
store the numbers from zero to 255
and so suppose we have the number 255
stored in a particular storage location
so here you can see
you know i've got all my bits on this is
the largest possible number i can store
in eight bits
and then i try and add one to it what
happens
well the natural thing if you recall our
last video on how to
how to add uh in binary and who can
forget that video
um what happened was uh when we added
one
we had that carryover and we had to
carry over and we had to carry over and
we had a carryover and it finally
carried over to the far
left and you can see what happens is the
ninth
bit gets flipped to one but guess what
we don't have nine bits
we only have eight bits because this
particular value is only being started
eight bits so what happens is that
that ninth bit gets discarded there's no
space for it
and what has happened is our very large
value consisting of all ones has flipped
to a
very low value consisting of all zeros
so in terms of what's happening for
decimal
we have a 255 which is the equivalent of
having all
the bits in a particular byte switched
to one
we have 255 we've added one to 255 and
we've actually ended up with zero
so this is overflow so for our next
example we're going to take a look at
what happens when
we have a large positive number
but we're storing in a space that is
allowed to store both positive and
negative numbers
so in this particular case again i'm
just going to store
all of our data in a single byte which
allows us to store numbers between
positive 127 and negative 128.
now there are a number of different ways
to store negative numbers on the
computer
the simplest way to store a negative
number on the computer is something
called sine magnitude representation
inside and magnitude representation what
we're going to do is
we're going to take the high end bit and
we're going to go ahead and say if it's
a 0 we have a positive number and if
it's a 1 we have a negative number
so in the case of our single byte the
way this would work is
the seven low end bits would go ahead
and represent our number
and then the eighth bit would represent
whether we had a positive number or a
negative number
it turns out that this has a number of
problems though most notably
it gives us both a positive zero and a
negative zero
so if all the bits are zero that's a
regular zero and if all the bits are
zero except for the leftmost bit is one
that's a negative zero so that's kind of
a problem
so there are several other schemes used
but the most common one is something
called
two's complement i'm not going to go
into detail and two's complement i think
we spend enough time on math for today
but
the key point on all of these schemes is
that left most bit is going to represent
whether or not we have a positive or
negative number
so what we're going to do now is we're
going to go ahead and take our
largest positive number which again
leftmost bit is zero
that represents we have a positive
number and all the other seven bits are
one
this represents a positive 127.
we're going to go ahead and add one to
it and you can see what happens here is
that most bit flips to a one
this means we have a negative number and
in fact using this
standard two's complement representation
this is actually a negative 128 so what
has happened is
we've had a very large positive number
127 we've added one to it we've got 128.
so
this is again an example of overflow
so when you're working with a computer
program or you're working with some sort
of application
and you think everything's going great
and suddenly
your bank account gets reset to zero or
your bank account which was at a million
dollars gets set to
negative a million what's probably
happening here is
overflow this probably means whoever
wrote the program did not do a very good
job
okay i've got one more type of error i
want to introduce you
and this is i suppose it's not actually
technically an error
what we're going to see here is that
when we're working with
binary numbers our intuition on
what results should come up is not
necessarily correct
and so what i mean by that is we're
going to add some numbers together
and the results should be very very
obvious to us
when working with decimal but we'll see
that the computer has some different
ideas
on what the answer should be so what i'm
running here is
this is the python interpreter this is a
way in which i can
interactively enter commands in the
python programming language
this is the programming language that
cs105 students will be using a little
bit later on this quarter
and so what i'm going to do is i'm going
to add some numbers here so let's let's
ask the python interpreter to take 0.1
and add it to 0.2 and what is 0.1 plus
0.2 well naturally it's 0.3 let's see if
the python interpreter agrees with us
whoa what is this okay let's try another
one
let's ask the python interpreter to add
0.7
to 0.1 see it's pretty clear this should
be 0.8 right
okay python interpreter let's see what
you got what
okay so what what is going on here is is
this computer just completely messed up
now what's actually going on here is
that
numbers that we can represent in decimal
in a set number of decimal places
is not the same base 10 and base 2.
so you may recall that there are certain
numbers that we cannot represent in a
fixed number of decimal places so let's
say
i tell you to write the decimal
equivalent of
two-thirds well what is the decimal
number
equivalent of two-thirds well you might
say it's 0.67 but
that's not actually accurate i could say
no
0.66667 is a more accurate
representation and in fact
the correct representation would be this
0.6 repeating
where this bar above the 6 represents a
repeating decimal
where that 6 is repeated forever ever
and ever and ever
so the problem we're running into here
is it turns out that
the binary number has different
repeating numbers than the decimal
number system and
in particular the number 0.1 and base 10
you know obviously it's very finite 0.1
there you go that's the answer
it does not have a finite value in
binary in binary it's 0.0 and then
zero zero one one repeating so for
example zero point zero zero zero one
one zero zero one one zero zero one one
zero zero one one and so on
and there's no set number of there's no
finite number
of places after the decimal point so
what's happening here is
we're taking these numbers where we are
sure that there's a set number of
decimal places like
0.7 plus 1.1
and we're getting a number that does not
have a natural endpoint and so that's
why these numbers are slightly off
as a result of this programmers are
cautioned
not to use floating point numbers when
representing money
because you will get these slight
variations that will cause your customer
to be like
wait what what is going on here
all right so there's obviously a lot
more that can go wrong with
computing and in fact we'll see some of
it later in the quarter
but for now that's it for a little
exploration of what can go wrong
when we're working with binary numbers
you